[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe what's up everybody hey
babe look who it is DeRosa
Sal's Sal's uh sounds uh we'll be back
soon uh just got got uh busy filming
Impractical Jokers and um and so now uh
Joe and I are here together and we're
gonna do hey babe I'm gonna do taste
buds and that's what it's gonna be okay
because it's the no pressure Network and
don't you forget it there you go dude
you're [ __ ] first of all it actually
made me angry it made me actually angry
yesterday because you're such a [ __ ]
pig and and I went to see you do your
hour your new hour at uh New York Comedy
Festival and I was expecting to go in
there and boo you and be like and just
watch a joke fail and just laugh in the
back and you [ __ ] crushed with like
good thought out material and and then
and you and you did it all in plaid
pants
and then and but the material was so
good and then to make the plaid pants
worse you put on a mustard Overcoat yeah
like like you know like you were like it
was like you were a woman from the 1970s
right and I was so angry I was like I
wanted to make so many jokes about your
outfit and be like oh I hate it blah
blah but I just kept saying how good
your bits were because they were good
thank you thank God I still hope the
nurses cancel you
I remember uh I wouldn't I remember last
night when you walked in
as you could just see my big goofy head
I'm embarrassed or vintage I mean I got
like a little nervous when you walked in
because I was like oh like my friends
here now and like yeah I hope it keeps
going well I remember the part when you
walked in I like I like stumbled for a
second I forgot a line and I had to like
go back in the middle of the joke and
like reinsert the line that I forgot it
was like a hot chick walking in yeah
yeah
a big thick [ __ ] yeah big thick
[ __ ] dude I I and you know we can
edit this out uh uh if you don't want if
it like spoils a bit I don't think it
does but dude I was dying laughing to
learn that your own cut that out okay
I'm sorry sorry because I was a surprise
in the show okay okay all right yeah
because all right so so forget forget
that one we'll talk about that but that
was like legitimately uh just go see his
material it was [ __ ] if even I'm
telling you to go see it and I want
nothing more than Joe to just [ __ ]
you know get hit by a bus and survive is
is I'm telling you it's good dude dude
look at we're New Balances now
but are these cool though look oh what
look it's the Amy Lynn uh what is it aim
Leon Dior are these good pimp what are
you thinking new about aren't new
balance is back in they're fine they're
fine they're fine they're comfortable
I'm literally wearing them because I'm
like I can walk on the city all day and
they're comfortable remember when
remember when you weren't allowed to
wear New Balances because they voted for
Trump
well these voted for him too look at
that look at those things dude dude you
got white green chaos has the Amelia
Earhart [ __ ] new balance is on dude I
got a show and bought I got a show in
Boston this weekend I'm gonna wear it
just to [ __ ] it because it's Celtics
color dude I got reprimanded we had
Bobby Kelly we had Bobby Kelly on
Facebook oh look Colin Quinn's calling
me should I pick it up yeah yeah pick it
up that pig Colin
all right well here here first of all
let me tell you right now I'm sitting
here doing a podcast with Joe DeRosa any
words for Joe DeRosa
you know what's better English muffins
or french toast or whatever
Colin how's it going why are you calling
Chris DeStefano of all the numbers you
could have scrolled past why did you
land and to choose Christa Stefano
well I'll tell you what I'll tell you
what then I'll call you back in a little
bit I'll tell you how it went last night
the man of the hour never showed up so I
waited there for an hour and a half and
I just instead of meeting the guy who I
was supposed to meet I all I did was
Meet Billy Hayes childhood friends uh I
ate [ __ ] fried calamari with you know
with [ __ ] uh uh you know Henry o or
whatever from Marine Park
so I didn't even meet the guy that we
were supposed to [ __ ] meet
but it's fine
there is Chris his connection is Billy
Hayes
Bill all right I'll call you later Colin
yeah Billy Hayes by the way good uh
friend of ours that we all know Billy he
showed up to a dinner last night he has
no front tooth he said he bit into a
mango in the Dominican Republic and his
tooth snapped out what his Pig I love
Billy ages one of my favorite guys on
Earth he's an absolute Pig he sent me we
were oh wait sir I got to tell you so
this also taste was related Billy Hayes
the other day sent me a picture because
we talked about the Land of Lakes butter
girl
on uh taste buds like if she's hot or
not yeah yeah that she was hot and Billy
Hayes sent me a picture of Land O'Lakes
butter and he was like did you ever as a
kid fold the Box because if you fold the
Box a certain way her knees it looks
like she's holding her boobs what yeah
Billy Hayes is Jeffrey Dahmer I know he
goes no we all did this as kids and he
goes you ever do that I go no I came
from a good family yeah yeah I gave him
a good family I wasn't I wasn't I wasn't
raised by hoodlums in Brooklyn so crazy
dude but but but the other the thing I
was going to tell you about Boston was
we had Bobby Kelly on taste buds okay
skinny Bobby yeah he was the one that
brought the land of lakes girl but
anyway he uh because he misses how much
butter did Bobby used to eat yeah he
misses it dude he looks great now he
does he does
um he uh he like said oh oh he was like
sitting like this okay and he had on
like a sort of like kind of like a hip
New York outfit and I made fun of him
and I said I said you can't sit like
that in Boston they're so homophobic
like they won't let me go home like that
some dumb joke like that some guy wrote
to me and he goes listen dude I'm a big
fan I love you you were way off base
with that Boston comment it's not
homophobic here anymore it's not racist
yes anyways by the way nothing to let
you know something homophobic and racism
somebody telling you it's not homophone
of course it is [ __ ] unbelie dude
yeah I mean Boston Boston is one of
those cities for whatever reason again
we love Boston by the way I love Boston
the guy took it that seriously good so
you realize what a lunatic you have to
be to even write someone to even write
to someone about that to even write to
someone and say I I was offended by your
joke do you think that that guy you
think that guy uh who wrote that is he's
probably in the closet but but
speaking of that I think you should talk
about the concert you went to this week
oh hell yeah oh The 1975 dude
yeah bro
look at that no I know I mean I don't
know what about it how about this I
swear to God and shout out to whoever
this kid was because it made everyone
around me laugh and I had no company you
bought the sweatshirt yeah 85 bucks
dude I'm a fan look I'm a fan of the
Bands I go to see too I I never buy the
sweatshirt is always the biggest ripoff
of the merch I know the T-shirt was 40
bucks I guarantee you too I guarantee
you too this doesn't have the good
lining on it it's got the pilly yeah
yeah look at that dude that's got one
maybe two watches in it at most and then
it's fine and then it shrinks no this is
so pilly dude that's gonna come out what
does pilly mean like like if you wore
this on a white T-shirt and you took it
off you would have black stuff all over
your T-shirt oh so they cheat they
cheaped out on the material dude look at
that thing you thought this looked like
a Crawley The 1975 or quality it looks
like they [ __ ] airbrushed that on
what was the average age there so the
average age was was 23 year old girls
and gay guys
um and then I went with Jasmine but we
were literally we were sitting down we
were sitting
um it was hotter the guys or the girls
dude the guys were bro this one guy was
dancing the whole night he was a gay guy
with no shirt on I just kept looking at
him dude he [ __ ] just his rhythm I
was like holy [ __ ] but literally some
fan somebody yelled you know before the
concert started you know he could kind
of like you know that it was after the
openers went on it was an interim
between the openers going on and 1975 he
had like 20 minutes so we're all just
chilling getting ready and uh somebody
else out yo Chrissy so like I look up
and it goes I thought that it was just a
bit you liked in 1975 but I guess you
really are gay and dude if he yelled
that in public in in New York City and
it [ __ ] killed and even Jasmine was
laughing at me I know come back but when
they started playing those songs I was
like I don't know dude I just got
entranced by the music I love the music
so much and Jasmine was like this is
you're like really like letting loose I
was like yeah I [ __ ] love this band
really were you dancing yeah I was and I
wore my Deutschland Special Olympics
jacket did you cry any heartfelt moments
no I didn't cry but when they played um
a couple of the songs from when I got
into them like some of their older hits
I got you know pretty nostalgic and I
was like wow
and then Alex Edelman was there Alex
Edelman knows the band
oh adamant oh wait I thought you meant
Alex our ad guy for a second I got Alex
the ad guy no Alex Edelman is a great
comic from New York or Boston uh yeah he
knows the band so he we were gonna maybe
hang with the band he was like I'll text
you if I meet up with them I'll let you
know like what's going on and then I
just kind of was a lie I love a lie when
I hear I know I never got it bro I swear
I'll text you let me just go check it
out and uh yeah well but but then even
just like who didn't show up oh god well
no Jasmine she goes I was like oh we
should wait around and she goes Chris
you're acting like a loser yeah she
literally looked at me she goes you're
acting like a loser wait around
she goes Chris she I was like this band
whatever she goes you're like she goes I
know they're playing MSG because she was
like you know like you're sucking their
dicks she was like and I get it that you
love the band she's like but you're
waiting outside like a fangirl and then
she starts looking out she goes you have
more followers than the band and she was
like what are you talking besides the
lead singer she was like what are you
doing and I was like no Jazz like this
is important to me she's like she was
like she actually made she put it on me
she was like she was like you know how
like when you do your show when you do
your stand-up show at a smaller venue
than MSG of course she's like but you do
a stand-up show and then people come
into the Green Room that you don't know
and you want to die because you just
performed you just gave it your and then
you have to make small talk he was like
that's how they'll feel about you yeah
so why would you not just go through
whatever proper channels you have if you
really like them maybe you can meet with
them and get them on the podcast do
something in a professional space yeah
and stop waiting around like a fan girl
go into the bar they're at jazz is so
smart you don't deserve her yeah she
really is just better than you dude I
literally put a video up of hers like
singing along to this or not sing along
kind of just looking at me and all the
comments she received a million comments
I received a a million comments from
from my Ig guy told me like everyone's
just saying how beautiful she is and how
I don't deserve it I'm gonna [ __ ]
move into your house like The Watcher if
you're a [ __ ] Mansion I'm gonna hit
on Jazz like the way the security guy in
that show bags the 15 year old daughter
yeah dude I love that I love that on
Staten Island what my house would be
considered a mansion doesn't even have a
finished basement but that's good they
didn't have a finished Pavements on The
Watcher either that's the whole thing is
they have to finish the base
don't show stunk the ending of the I
know we spoke about it the the ending of
The Watcher is going to be infuriating I
will say why because there's no closure
there's no closure at all dude there's
no closures because because God forbid
they don't they don't turn it into a
second season which they're doing they
got picked up for a second they all
right same thing same thing I watched
Inside Man with Stanley Tucci and who's
got the hairiest Forums on the planet
it's like if I was Stanley Tucci because
you can't have like little baby you know
hairless upper arms and then just a
hairy form it looks [ __ ] weird yeah
and uh he looked like look like a baby
chimp and he has a body like a baby
chimp and um and um so that show I was
it's it's about the inside man it's
about a guy you know Stanley too she
plays like all you got to know is he
he's a he's in prison for murder and the
whole concept of the show is everybody
can have one bad day and murder someone
it just takes the right circumstance and
the right person so and it was a mini
series so I'm thinking okay the fourth
episode you're gonna find out why
Tucci's in jail you're gonna find out
the couple that they were talking about
why they did what they did have an
ending what are they going to do with
this person that they've abducted and
you don't it just ends on a cliffhanger
and I'm like why like it [ __ ] with the
art so much where it's like dude I I
need closure like now you're just gonna
drag this story on just make another
[ __ ] just finish this one finish the
Watcher and then make something else
yeah I I agree man like I don't
understand you could you could do
another show with that money you could
do the Watchers should have been four
episodes
at the most maybe five I mean just a
short film by the way let me it was yeah
it was just too it just goes on that
[ __ ] private detective on that show
the lady they hire there's literally a
moment in every episode she's in where
she has solved the case right and then
in the next episode she's completely
wrong and then she goes I have figured
it out it's like you would be like lady
you are [ __ ] fired yeah you were
fired you don't know what you're doing
like it's but here's the weird part I
read the real story it's it's weirdly
like pretty close to it it's not that
different it's not well they said that
they've embellished they've said that
they've embellished details and they
combined two stories what the real story
is supposedly is just the Watcher
um uh somebody just left uh notes in a
mailbox they all the other stuff killing
the animals that's all made up no no
that stuff was but like the thing where
they become Pariah is in the
neighborhood oh yeah like all that stuff
I think was real yeah the the gamer the
gamer tag thing was real the internet
handle oh okay like a guy they knew like
he was that was right but it wasn't the
security guy which was a terrible that
was terrible when they were just like
it's just a coincidence that your
security guy is called The Watcher yeah
when he goes on Xbox it was so stupid
I've been getting so much worse as the
decades go on like why can't people
write your show I could tell you why I
could tell you exactly why pimp I'm glad
you asked you thank you for bringing
that up by the way anytime I never
noticed something about Joe but anytime
he makes fun of me or says anything all
I'm gonna go back to is that this is a
grown man that has multiple commas
tattooed on his arm
could you imagine you had it's multiple
comments tattooed on his arm and he gets
to see he yells at me about scripture on
my form he has commas he has [ __ ]
punctuation well I know
what you guys promised them tattoos you
force each other to agree to tattoos
that you never I'm working I'm working
on my Hoagie tattoo as we speak
of Verrazano Bridge tattooed on your arm
if I got a hoagie all right I'm I'm
still down for that because what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna put the Verrazano
Bridge on I'm gonna put my kids names
through it too just to make it even more
sad or maybe I'll have to brows out on
Bridget I'll just on the other side I'll
just have Jesus you know Jesus Christ
with an American flag over him
how great would that be Jesus with an
American flag on him is it great this
couch that we said you promised that was
August of last of 21. yeah that was the
last time he came to my house yeah dude
I haven't seen it now I haven't seen it
in I realized because I thought it was
August of this year it was August of
last year was the last time I came here
I don't know if you noticed that Joe's
now back into painting what do you think
about Joe's art wait wait wait I want to
answer your question that's going to be
a meaty thing I know don't trust me it's
not lost on me we'll get in oh wow I
just noticed that now oh my God but I
want to answer your question about why
writing sucks it's it's two things
number one the pandemic and you're
seeing like the Fallout of like pandemic
product is bad everywhere now it's down
and you're seeing except for Joey Rose's
sandwich yeah except for Joey's sandwich
shop and no pressure no pressure yeah
stand-up comedy baby I am coming to
Toronto November 17th 18th Buffalo
November 19th all the shows almost sold
out but go to christycomedy.com for
Ticky Wiki's brand new stand-up hour so
go check it and then we got New Year's
Eve in Huntington Long Island and we got
the South Charleston South Carolina and
North Carolina December uh 15 to the
17th uh all the tickets are almost sold
out but go take a peek christycomedy.com
for Ticky Wiki's brand new hour yeah
babe you need to learn a new language
Babel is the only one that I'd suggest
I've been using it as you know my family
speaks Spanish now I could speak better
Spanish because of Babel they um it's
it's fine it's easy it's like these
little bite-sized lessons and what I
love about them the most is it's a team
of language experts that made the app
it's not some robotic software okay it's
actual people we're not in Boston
Dynamics lab here making up language
apps these are real people language
experts that made this app and I like
that with Babel you can choose from 14
different languages including Spanish
French Italian and German and Babel
speech recognition technology helps you
improve the pronunciation and accent and
that's key the bat it's the it's all
about the accent you know anybody can
say you know some dumb word anybody
could say you know yo soy Christopher
you know but it's like
that's what Babel teaches you
um start a new language learning Journey
today with Babel right now if you go to
babel.com hey babe that's babble.com hey
babe you're gonna get 55 off your
subscription okay that's a lot of
freaking money that's more than half off
55 off your subscription if you go to
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com
hey babe Babble Lang was Learning for
Life
what's up guys big announcement first of
all the IJ tour is going on right now
the pre-sales is going on right now uh
and they go on sale Friday morning uh
which is tomorrow morning and it is the
pre-sale code is IJ Drive we're coming
to a ton of cities so go to
impracticaljokerslive.com for tickets
and then come see your boy uh October
28th I'm in Richmond Virginia October
29th two in Hershey in Pennsylvania and
then the following weekend we got
Knoxville November 11th two in Atlanta
on November 12th and Alabama Birmingham
November 13th everything on sale right
now at savocano comedy.com I'll see you
there but you're seeing the product drop
in almost everything now right and like
like service these Services everything
like no matter no matter what it is like
there's a quality drop off because of
supply chain issues because of staffing
issues all these things my a coffee shop
down the street from here they've
assigned in the window and they're like
guys we're really sorry we can't it's a
coffee shop they're like we can't be
open during the day anymore because we
have stamped so many staffing issues
well like so when do they open at night
at night dude what what at night just I
probably just to stay afloat
you know oh my God because you know they
used to they used to I think they used
to close at night too which is crazy
dude
these staffing issues are like my my
friend opened up uh uh like a bakery
that serves breakfast uh near me And he
was like I can't get a cook like I
cannot get a cook he was like no but
nobody will take this job which is like
because the pandemic's been over the
fact that the fact that well here's the
thing it's not over it's just not as
much of a threat as it was but they
still have yet to address it in the
proper way if they've still have not
addressed it as an endemic right they
keep addressing it as a pandemic they're
not addressed they've this is well you
had the opportunity to vote for change
and you didn't this was the wrong wave
is coming this was never sorry this is
hey babe not chaos sorry this was never
addressed or handled in the appropriate
way but that's a whole other thing the
the the but the point is is
uh you're seeing the the quality hit of
all that right but then also too you're
living in a like we talked about this
one we'll see you in hell like Pat was
like I don't understand why like
everybody's like he was talking about
the new Fletch movie and he was like I
don't understand why everybody's talking
about this movie being so great it's not
that good and I go Pat because we're
living in a culture right now where you
can't criticize anybody now forget the
immediate reality of that where it's
like you like I talked about it in the
show less and I'm like you can't you
can't yell at employees anymore like you
can't I'm not saying that as a boss like
I'm not saying I want to I'm just saying
like if I if I needed to you could you
can't like if you just we don't live in
that reality anymore it like like staff
changes all that stuff has to be handled
so differently now and that does affect
quality control in its own in its own
and I'm just talking generally I'm not
talking my own experience but
we're also living in a thing where we we
live in a full-on corporatocracy now
everything has been corporatized right
and you just look at it with the
entertainment industry I go pet
everybody that is online that's talking
about how great this movie is they're
all in the entertainment business they
can't criticize it
because everything is corporatized now
you can't criticize this thing because
not only do you know three people that
work on it right if you don't know three
people that work on it you know another
person that's working on a thing that
you're working on that's connected to
this or you just don't want to be
everything extreme now you don't want to
be on the outs with Netflix by saying a
Netflix project or whatever it is sucks
so so there's no real criticism anymore
and then when criticism does happen it's
a lot of the look at look look at the
way people
my [ __ ] bar it's five star reviews or
one star reviews this podcast it's five
star reviews or one star reviews taste
buds five star reviews are one star
reviews YouTube comments this is the
greatest thing ever or I hate this and I
hope you all [ __ ] die uh Rotten
Tomatoes 98 from critics 22 from the
audience it's like dude that what
happened to just like balance whatever
anymore would you just go yeah man like
here's my nuanced take on a thing you
know what I mean like it just doesn't
exist anymore yeah look at Amazon
reviews it's five star reviews and one
star reviews and you and then on top of
it you don't know what's real and what's
not you look at five star reviews you go
did they pay for these is these people
that work for them doing these whatever
you look at one star reviews you go are
these trolls is this real like right how
could anything be of full quality
anymore
when this is the when this is the
climate you live in you can't it's it's
insane like when when and I'm not just
saying this because I'm a mom-and-pop
proprietor when you find a mom-and-pop
business that you like that makes a good
product support it because that is a
[ __ ] unfound commodity anymore and
it's gonna keep going away my kids my
just the other day like you know like
cold stone is like you know great ice
cream whatever I [ __ ] love Chrissy
Coldstone I love I love Cold Stone ice
cream I hate your nickname so much dude
that's it's literally what I'm defined
by I know yeah oh my god dude it's your
[ __ ] Larry the Cable Guy yeah dude
it's what I'm taking it to the bank dude
oh my God I can't wait to be doing
Arenas and then it's just because of my
nicknames I need wait finish your point
well I took I took you know my kids you
know we go to Cold Stone uh a lot more
than we should but whatever and um and
my daughter was like I I don't like she
was like all like she was like isn't
there like a place where like you know
nobody's wearing uniforms like somewhere
with my daughter was like like she she
doesn't know how to articulate but she's
like is there a place where people
aren't wearing uniforms or we could eat
ice cream so I think in her mind she's
saying like a mom and pop so I took her
to this place in my neighborhood when my
I grew up called Eddie's sweet shop and
it's been an ice cream shop there since
the 1920s right and it's like looks like
you're walking back in time and it's
literally you know people in Eddie sweet
shop like a mom-and-pop shop where they
give you ice cream like in a dish and
it's like this it's not the whole song
and dance elaborate scheme of cult so I
don't even know Cold Stone's amazing
it's like this little Mom and Pop shop
and my daughter loved that ice cream
like so much more than like love the
experience of it so much more that I was
like oh [ __ ] I gotta start taking her
like like the fact that my kids don't
get excited don't have a Toys R Us it's
really like it sucks because that's like
some of my Fondest Memories like going
to Toys R Us yeah and now Amazon getting
things in boxes like yeah my kids like
it but when when we take them to an
actual toy store The Joy like it's like
a whole experience that that they're
just lost and that's the thing too that
was a bummer like Toys R Us
I I had a Toys R Us near me in uh when I
lived in LA right you don't have a Toys
R Us near me when you lived in
Pennsylvania no well we had Kitty city
was our toy store whoa nice sounds like
a pedo store you know it was awesome
though it was an awesome store Kitty
City yeah we had Toys R Us too but Kitty
city was our main one but anyway I had a
Toys R Us near me when I lived in LA and
I would go because they had video games
so I would go in and buy video games
in your late 30s when you were doing
that dude I do it now in my mid-40s
honestly dude I think that you figured
it out though I think you're living the
freest life of all of us and I kind of
[ __ ] it kind of like I'm kind of Envy I
am an absolute Pig on the loose dude
there's no stopping me oh yeah I do
whatever I want whenever I feel like
yeah whatever anytime you see any time
any time you uh see Joe on a late night
Instagram story just look for the hoof
Prince on the cement and then you'll
know what bar you want to but dude I'm
telling you something like it was a
bummer because I would go into the Toys
R Us and I would sometimes just walk
around it because it was like for
Nostalgia I'd be like it's like cool
it's like a twister and dude it was a
bummer like because they were on their
way out but just the way those stores
even looked before they closed yeah they
didn't look and feel like toy stores no
no they felt like warehouses yeah it
felt like a Kmart that just had you know
or or like a Walmart but it but it had
toys instead of of you know Home Goods
but like that's why like I think like
not even it didn't even feel as as warm
and welcoming as a Walmart what Walmart
is not a very like warm environment it's
just it feels like sort of industrial
you know right
I want to just [ __ ] like fi like
where's like a good Village like I want
to just like go I want to like drive and
take my family like a nice Village dude
I wanna that's all I want I dream about
moving to it I wouldn't want to go
I'll tell you a great place New Hope
Pennsylvania
there's a great Hotel there called
odette's by the river it's one of the
best times I've ever had in my life I
stayed there last year for Halloween
it's great dude I I have like all kinds
of alerts on my I'm like trying to find
a affordable we're gonna move to New
Hope Pennsylvania no I wanna but Sal's
never gonna come to the bus
I just want to buy a house out in
Pennsylvania as a as an investment like
the Poconos yeah I was thinking about
Pokemon Poconos I decided against
ultimately it was like a little too
remote and I don't know anybody in that
area yeah like I know people in like the
New Hope area like I could go down there
and see my friends and stuff New Hope is
I've multiple times driven from even
when I was living in Brooklyn just drove
to New Hope Pennsylvania for the day
it's awesome over there it's great
there's a bridge that George Washington
crossed but dude here's the other thing
too like like
like it's everything's just breaking
down dude like people don't like do we
have this I I it's funny because I it
might sound like it's just an experience
that I'm having personally but I do
think it's indicative of kind of what's
that we had this thing going on at the
bar
where we have to constantly tell
these 15 year old and it's when I say
these 15 year old kids I don't mean the
same five there's like four different
packs of 15 year old kids like guys you
can't just sit like in our outdoor space
yeah you can't just do it like this is
for like customers and stuff and they're
nice they're nice kids they're not
shitty
what are they doing out there what are
they getting into they just sit dude
they just sit sometimes I've I've caught
them I've caught them I've caught him
trying to smoke weed in there and I have
to be like what in your in your trailer
thing outside yeah yeah well you have to
just constantly Chase packs of kid dude
this is like old school New York [ __ ]
that's hilarious dude this is the most
Wild Thing This is the most Wild Thing
This last night dude last night I was in
there after we did the show at black
with your mustard yellow pea coat on
yeah yeah yeah dude this kid comes
walking in dude she was like 15. I go I
go buddy you gotta get out of here this
is a bar you're not allowed in here he
goes I just want to use the bathroom I
go you're not allowed yeah you you'll
legally yeah and not walk and he goes
and the kid was like I don't understand
man he was like going back and forth
with me and then finally he was like
listen to me I was like dude you have to
go right now yeah and he left
and I go dude this is insane I go when I
was 15 this is what I this is what I'm
saying is indicative of what's going on
when I was 15 I understood what laws
were right like I understood like I'm
not allowed in that place I'm not 21.
like I feel like and and I I feel like
the point is is illustrated by the fact
that it's not one group of kids you
can't point to it and go these four kids
you know their parents are another thing
it's a completely a generational thing
right and it's like they don't even
under and again they're nice kids like
they're they come from like decent homes
and [ __ ] they have manners right but
they don't understand like the way the
world works it's crazy yeah nobody's
crazy because Chris is going to be at
the center of this in the next few years
yeah dude my daughter's seven dude she's
literally the the timing is working out
where like when in about eight years it
could be like full world upheaval and
she'll be a [ __ ] teenage girl dude
it's gonna be insane there's gonna be
like riots in the streets and then I
have to deal with a teenage daughter you
think it'll be that bad do you think
it's gonna like I think the middle class
is going to go away listen I'm
optimistic I always try to be optimistic
I guess because I am a dad I try to be
optimistic if at the very least at least
just convince myself and lie to myself
that at home my daughter see an
optimistic uh person
um but I do feel here's why I think my
father is 75 years old and my father is
like this is the worst time I've ever
experienced my dad's saying that he's
like and he lived through the 70s in New
York and he lived through all that he's
like this is the he goes this is so much
worse and because he said there really
is it feels like no way to fix this he
goes you saw like he was telling me like
in the 70s you could see the problems
like you could see that and he said we
also like we weren't all connected he
goes the fact that we're all connected
now with social media he thinks he was
telling me that in 2009 I swear to God
and I've said it before on podcast my
dad I remember exactly where I [ __ ]
was where it was a Joe and John's
pizzeria on Myrtle Avenue which has one
of the best Sicilian slices in Queens so
go check it out and they have teeth now
that now they have new owners and they
have the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
your tagos society's crumbling I'll take
200 on black yeah yeah yeah
my dad would have heart-to-hearts to me
at Joe and John's Pizzeria but it's
[ __ ] it was it's great though it's
still great but anyway he said to me he
goes Twitter he goes you know this is
horrible because he was like not
everybody's supposed to be talking he
was like Society is supposed to have
some people that talk and some people
that don't he goes you can't give
everyone the floor I swear to God when
Twitter first came out I hit a bit where
I said doesn't anybody realize how bad
this is you realize you're not supposed
to put everything that leaks into your
head yeah into public right conversation
that was like the biggest when my mom
and I would argue that was the biggest
thing like you know that was always my
biggest criticism with her when we would
fight was I would go do you where is the
filter like everything that pops up into
your head it just falls out of your
mouth like do you understand that it's
insulting sometimes right to just say
what you think like right you know what
I mean like that was a thing that like
it's just your dad's 100 right and then
also too
I took it out I'm gonna probably put it
back in I had a thing in the show about
this about like when you can see because
the new the new hour I'm doing is all
it's just it's hopeless like that's
that's the whole thing there's no hope
there's no it will never get it's awful
I'll tell you a real Telltale my friend
makes you feel good my friend yeah my
friend who's uh who's who's very left
and not annoyingly like like he you know
he criticized like he's like he's like a
liberal in the way I feel like I'm not
advocating abortions at nine months the
uh
now a word from our sponsor betterhelp
let me tell you something times are
tough you know in the world uh we all
have mental health issues it's not a
shame you're not you know shameful to go
get help I've done it a lot of my
friends have done it and better help is
awesome you don't have to go to a
therapist therapist's office all you do
is sit from the comfort of your own home
on your laptop or phone they send you a
link and you're doing it right there all
online it's great they you take a little
quiz they match you up with a counselor
who's best for you and that's it and
right now if you go to
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p so betterhelp.com
hey babe you're gonna get uh 10 off your
first month so that's a good discount 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
hey babe telling you try therapy it
works for me it'll work for you
betterhelp.com hey babe 10 off your
first month doordash you know we love it
me and Sally babes talk about it every
week we use it all the time we'll
screenshot our doordash orders and send
them to each other because we're
literally we're probably using it too
much but it's great because you can get
healthy foods and go to the supermarket
it's not just you know you know getting
a meal here there it's like there's so
much more to offer in doordash and they
work with all the big chains you know
Cheesecake Factory Chipotle Popeyes
doordash is awesome they have over 300
000 Partners including you know big
chains and Mom and Pop shops so door
Dash shout out we like that you keep you
you care about those small businesses
um
for limited time our listeners can get
50 percent off up to a 20 value so spend
20 bucks you're gonna get 50 off and
zero delivery fees when you download the
doordash app and enter code hey babe22
okay so that's like legit that's like an
amazing deal so all you got to do is go
put doordash app put in promo code hey
babe 22 and you're gonna get 55 50 off
up to a 20 value that's 50 off up to a
20 value and zero delivery fees when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code hey babe22 don't
forget that's code hey babe22 for 50 off
up to twenty dollar value and zero
dollar delivery feeds with doordash
subject to change terms apply they're
like oh yeah you could kill it until
it's kindergarten yeah that's what I was
gonna say yeah
I feel good about that yeah I should
have been [ __ ] somebody this should
have been stopped dude yeah I was
adopted oh yeah I know God that even God
was like no I'm telling you to discard
it even the parents don't want it and
you're are taking it the uh but uh
what's it yo recipe you've always used
to say to me he goes DeRosa do you think
your parents knew what a complete
scumbag they were getting yeah
he goes somewhere on planet Earth your
real parents are going we dodged a
bullet with that one yeah you think I
get it like hey we adopted this kid you
may know him from Better Call Saul from
one episode but dude
here's the thing dude my friend I swear
to God my friend yesterday called me and
he go and he left me a voicemail and he
goes and you know he's very much like
dude you need to vote like you know
anything like I do believe in the in the
Democratic party for this reason or
whatever and like but he criticizes his
own party he gives accolades to the
right when they do things that he agrees
with like you know he was Republican at
one point actually uh or voted that way
my point is this he said on the
voicemail he left me yesterday he goes
I'm just driving home from voting yeah
because this time it's going to make a
difference and I was like whoa and he
was being sarcastic if this guy now is
talking like that like that's like
that's it like this this is it like
right people are
people I have never seen people as a
whole so completely hope the entire
country isn't supposed to be thinking in
Tim Dylan's voice
it is and that kid he did what's wrong I
mean that kid is buying [ __ ] houses
off of a podcast that he doesn't Charlie
Rose's old Studio
in that black room screaming well dude
you know what's crazy is yesterday you
know the voting voting what this come
out tomorrow right yeah so the you know
all the midterms whatever the voting you
know they said that like 60 percent of
the country is dissatisfied with Joe
Biden but then all the Democrats won the
election so that means people are like
wait we we we are dissatisfied with this
party but we're like [ __ ] it we'll still
vote for them it's it's it's literally
like yeah this this politically is not
good man I think that I think that
because everybody's desperate that's the
thing it's it's the parties now are
pushed into the extreme Wings right
there is no moderate aspect of either
party as far as the the legislation and
the leaders go it's all in my opinion
it's all been pushed now to the far
Wings the moderate people are the ones
that are going I'm done I don't see any
hope in any of this those are the
moderate people the people on either
side like you said about a late term
abortions right yeah abortions are great
a great thing to crystallize the
argument
the late term abortion is a thing that a
lot of the left support but their
response to that or their reasoning for
that is saying because the right wants
to get rid of it completely so if this
is the only way we can have it we're
going to have it this way yeah then
we'll set up your toddlers for a firing
squad right but then but then the right
term abortion
those are two such wildly extreme
stances to take but everybody is going
okay you forced me now whatever their
party is you force me now into an all or
nothing position and I am going to go
all or nothing I'm choosing to just go
guys I'm out I'm not I can't do this
anymore with anything I can't do it
anymore but the thing that's really
weird is like my cousin's a teacher and
all the little kids right when they grow
up they want to be an influencer so I'm
not worried about the old race
my friend's friend is a teacher my
friend's friend was a teacher he was
telling me that his friend who's a
teacher
he has students that are like like five
five years old six years old and they
there's a problem where the kids are
biting each other because they don't
know how to communicate because they
grew up in the lockdown right and they
don't know how to be social yeah so they
bite but it's falling apart is this what
you two to do hey babe today is this
what hey babe is like everywhere yeah
dude today I was gonna come back to this
[ __ ] disaster of itself
show dude literally today because
because the you know the Republicans
didn't really win much in the midterms
literally today I was driving two blocks
away from my house in Staten Island
somebody had a Chinese flag outside
their house because they're saying we
voted for coming it's crazy unlike you
six too extreme they haven't they that
means they bought a flag of from China
you know they're not Chinese they're I
know with the families they're white
people and they put a Chinese flag right
in their front lawn I was like wow dude
but whatever man I'm on edible I'm still
high from last let me ask you a question
I drove home last night on Edibles was
that like driving Under the Influence
yes so even it's not about alcohol but
how do they measure how much people
think that weed doesn't count when
you're driving in a hundred percent
counts it in pairs you can say it makes
you focus more you could say it makes
you a better driver you can say a
million things and maybe some of those
things are true it doesn't matter it's
it's an altering thing it's it's worse
than driving on medicines that are over
the the counter that they tell you not
to drive on you know what I mean but but
do you think like like you get pulled
over and you're on Edibles what are they
going to do they can't test your blood I
know you can get away with it but the
point is is if you kill a guy because
you're on [ __ ] edible you're driving
Under the Influence it doesn't matter
you still kill the guy and you go I
wouldn't have done that if I didn't I
was going like 20 miles an hour on the
highway Yeah well yeah yeah there was
nobody's gonna I was gonna kill but
maybe
I did yesterday I did my Canon's uh
edible shell where you take Edibles and
do crowd work dude it was what dude to
take Edibles taking animals terrifying
and doing crowd work it's crazy because
dude like I started like you know doing
like this this crowd work and not having
anywhere to go with it and then just
like stopping and like my mouth was
getting so dry and then I started
talking to these Indian guys in the
front row about like Indian politics and
and are you freaking out at all yeah
because because you know it's not
getting laughs and then like you just
see people looking at you and you're
like what the [ __ ] that sounds like a
nightmare nightmare dude and all I could
hear was Mike Cannon dying laughing in
the back or so I thought and then I was
like Mike oh thank God you were laughing
in the back it got me through it he goes
I wasn't in the room
I was like holy [ __ ] so I would do it
that the edible show yeah I Edibles I I
enjoyed I will say this I woke up I'm
still a bit stoned but I woke up this
morning because the there is a a a a a a
medicinal purpose to these Edibles
because when I woke up I had a way
better sleep when I woke up this morning
I just wasn't stressed like I wasn't
subtly angry at like you know my
daughter for not getting ready in time
because we're like gonna miss the bus
stop like I was just like hey would I if
we missed the bus I'll drive you to
school it's no problem like I had that
Vibe going like it's no problem like
everything is no problem so I think like
I should start doing that like weekly I
keep saying I'm gonna get into Ayahuasca
and do it and then I just and then I was
a different story yeah but we should do
it you're gonna like see demons and [ __ ]
yeah but I think I might have to do it
you guys have to do together that's the
podcast you will not I I will have a the
I've talked to people who've done
Ayahuasca and I'm like is it scary and
they're like dude it it it like you will
have a [ __ ] panic attack that's part
of it I don't want to do that yeah but
they say that cleanses you I hear you
I've had bad trips where I've had panic
attacks it is not fun
I get it Ayahuasca is a moderated thing
where you can you know I I understand
all that and maybe it does cleanse you I
do not want to go through that path of
hell like I don't I can't even take weed
dude it makes me I'm tortured now
because I've had to cut back way back on
drinking right if you feel like snort
Ajax when you were a kid what do you
mean what did it didn't you weren't you
one of those kids that like you did like
hard drugs in your teens and 20s in my
teens and 20s in my 30s and 40s
I thought you were one of those guys
like you were [ __ ] like literally
like you know drinking Pine-Sol like
like my party like that level of life
every day for years that's the hardest
drug
what's the hardest drug you've ever
taken but Coke how did you get that like
how do you trust a coke dealer yeah
I wouldn't do it now you can't do it now
there was a oh there was a time boys
there was a time where you could just
have a swell time uh well dude I I had a
friend who was so [ __ ] up he would
walk around with Narcan on him Jesus
Christ you know like how I don't know
how we got it but he's got multiple
Narcan shots no it's different it's a
different time now I wouldn't do I
wouldn't [ __ ] people think it's just
Coke you can't buy it's Adderall they're
putting they're putting uh fentanyl on
everything there's dude there's all
these always news stories they're
seizing these pill shipments that are
coming over the border and they're
finding they're singing a regular
over-the-counter medicine can I fentanyl
now well here's the thing people will
buy I don't know what the the unit is
called but people will buy massive
amounts of of prescription and sell it
illegally like Adderall that's a great
example
that now is getting made with fentanyl
probably because somebody's able to
produce it and and make you think that
you're buying the real thing when you're
not so who knows I'm sure it could
probably leak eventually into the real
dude it is we are this is it dude like
this is a terrible terrible terrible
time every not every but many many major
major intellectuals from around the
world are saying this is it like this is
as bad as it is yeah but it's been worse
than like it's not worse than like World
War II and they got out of that you know
that's always my thing it's like what
but like tell that to the people in
London or Germany in World War II it's
like well they came out of it but here's
well it's a different but it's a
different thing right Nancy Pelosi is
Hitler yeah it's a different thing I
mean World War II was a [ __ ] traffic
it was horrible obviously as bad as it
is you're going to miss right now when
the robots come yeah well that's the
thing we will look back on this and go
oh we didn't know how good we had it
people are doing that now
Bill Maher like when Bill Martin pisses
and moans about Trump he goes George W
bush I mean I didn't like him but he was
better than that like yeah like no
matter what the thing is that you hate I
had you will look back and go that
wasn't as bad as I thought it was and
listen uh whatever your stance is I know
it's controversial but like I had a
friend you know he came to me he he
didn't you know um he has kids and stuff
and and he came to me that you know
saying like his you know his wife is
pregnant again and you know they they
had money and whatever she's like but
you know we're considering you know
taking care of it get an abortion
because we genuinely are worried about
like there being a a a a a baby food
supply shortage again and we don't know
if like right now is a good time to
bring a baby into the world and 99 times
at 100 I say no you'll make it work and
I you know kind of said that still but
in my head I was like he's not like a
like I guess if you have a new baby
coming in there was a baby food shortage
last last year like that could happen
again and by the way by the way that
level of scrutiny
of in in having a child yeah
that should always be the level of
scrutiny right you you know so like
whether it's having a child or buying a
house or buying a car or putting your
thoughts on Twitter or putting a video
up or whatever it is
you I think now what we are seeing is
the backlash of people acting purely on
impulse not thinking any decisions
through not planning anything and what
happens is it's it's overpopulation it's
over saturation everything is it's it's
so much it's so much it's so much it's
so much and now you're seeing the
backlash of it right and now all of a
sudden people are going wait a second I
don't know if I thought this through but
what about and it's too [ __ ] late
right you can't ha I'm not saying that's
your friends I'm just saying like but
you can't you know like it is too late
for them it's too late a few nicknames
Patty fly balls it's too late I mean
what are you gonna do though it's like
you know how many people you know how
many people
for whatever reason like they're talk
there's articles about it now with like
the whole quiet quitting phenomenon
quiet quit oh yeah like basically you're
at work but you're not doing your job
it's short of that it's because I think
it's evolved into that but the idea of
it initially was just I'm not going to
take my job home with me oh okay now
look not taking your job home with you
and saying I'm not going to let my job
control my life is Backlash to to the to
the capitalist yeah whether you're
working 14-hour days which is horrible
right so so that was complete access and
whatever and then the backlash to that
is like okay now there's quiet quitting
I'm not going to take the job home with
me quiet quitting is evolving now into
I'm just not going to do my [ __ ] job
we hit a point coming out of the
lockdowns where it was two it was one
and a half jobs to every person which is
why when you go into a lot of places or
you call customer service or whatever it
is there's staffing issues
there's so many people they're people
just like yeah I'm not trying to get I'm
trying to get my whoop fitness band for
months and I can't get it because they
don't have the staff in there right I
want my look fitness band all right I
want to track my sleep and rest and
Recovery like Bert Kreischer right so
now so now a [ __ ] recession is about
to hit right or I think it already has
it it's hitting excuse me right yeah you
could tell about these ad numbers and my
patreon I know my God ah that is one
good thing about a recession is watching
Chrissy chaos patreon go down yeah just
[ __ ] it I watch it plummet like the Dow
Jones it's [ __ ] plummeting but here's
my point is
people now are going to be in a position
where they're going to the light bulb is
going to go off and go I don't know if I
thought this through I need a job now
and there's no jobs right well it's too
late the light bulb can't go off when
it's when you're in Paris yeah we
already kind of made our business work
with less workers and figuring it out so
now there's no room for you or when you
go in to get that job people are going
to go [ __ ] you I'm sticking with the
people that were there for me when I
needed them and now I have picked not me
I'm just saying anybody pick of the
litter right pick of the litter uh you
know I can I can get a stock broker to
pour coffee now yeah you know what I
mean so like my it's my point is in just
using the the thing the conversation
your friends are having about the kid I
think people start to have these real
I'm not saying them I'm just saying
people in general I think start to have
these realizations about planning and
and whatever
and but they're having them at the wrong
time and it's like it's like we all
should have been doing this all along
and we weren't and now we're in this
[ __ ] terrible so too you know what I
think is a big thing and then you know
what I think is this too serious are we
talking I mean I feel like sometimes you
gotta fight this is sometimes it's
different what do you want you know so
this is the episode I just everything
I'm on bombs no this will be fine I kind
of I still want you to talk you want to
save my painting for Taste yeah
I gotta but I will say but I think
sometimes it's good to have a little bit
of a different episode just [ __ ] keep
people on their toes that's what I think
we're not talking about we're not
talking you know we're not laughing at
videos of you know squirrels on skis
we're talking about real [ __ ] here your
children and everything you know and
love and everything you hope for in life
is not going to happen in this life so
I'm just gonna have to die and get
reincarnated and try and [ __ ] start
it again okay kill yourself no no
this has been hey babe
no real quick I just want to say I think
too something that we should be doing or
something that I is everybody like and
I'm doing this myself is like instead of
trying to get more and more and more and
how do I make more money and do this
it's like just try to figure out how to
live comfortably with what you got I
think that's what we have to do now in
this economy and that's like a hopeful
thing is how do I maintain the current
life I have what adjustments do I have
to make why do I have to Pivot people
have lost sight of it this is what I was
going to say earlier that I wanted to
put back into my show uh that I had
taken out this is all this episode was
it's just Joe doing his bits in long
form
no what your dad said about the about us
being connected why it's so bad
dude
uh uh uh the the the act of being gauche
and flaunting let's go she's that from
Ari special
Jew but you know what I mean go see that
flaunting yeah um you know like all this
stuff like it when you're rubbing that's
what because that's all you see on these
other things is all that hashtag best
life [ __ ] you go on and you see
people pretending it's all [ __ ] but
it's hard to tell and you have plenty of
people out there that can't tell that
it's fake
you go online and all you see is I got
this and look at me here and I'm with
this person and you're not and I ate
this amazing meal and I have this and
I've you see that all day and you're
somebody that doesn't have [ __ ] well
guess what right that's when people
start going okay you want me to be
[ __ ] desperate I'll be [ __ ]
desperate right I'm coming to your house
now right and I'm gonna take from you
yeah what you're rubbing in my face I'm
gonna rob you from it and now that's
that's that's it's everywhere dude you
can't go on the internet without it
looking like you're living a worse life
than everybody you're looking at well
now now I've made it like when I did
went to the 1975 concert just a couple
days ago I instead of I I posted one
video early on in the show just for 10
seconds and I said put my phone away I
said I want to live in the moment I
don't need to I don't need to document
this for everyone else that I was here
I'm here for me and that's it and I
enjoyed the concert so much more by not
like having a pro because I would go
through this thing so it's like I gotta
prove that I was here it's if you know
so if it ain't on the gram it don't
count it's like I don't live that like
that dude it's insane I took I'd rather
not I'd rather you not know I was there
I saw Cypress Hill and KRS one a couple
weeks ago I took a couple videos I sent
them to my buddies yeah like my buddies
from high school like dude check it out
remember we used to listen to this song
yeah I'm here like that's who I sent it
to once in a while I'll put it up and I
put it up as like an Accolade to the
artist like dude this guy is amazing
like go see this show whatever it's
never like look at me right uh you know
what I mean or at least it's never meant
to be but this this concept but be in
the [ __ ] moment Man live your life I
only posted my videos and tagged in 1975
so they would let me into their after
party that Alex Edelman got into I love
it I know dude Alex Edelman got it [ __ ]
go see JoJo's at the crane theater yeah
yeah December 14th crane theater go do
it dude and I'll yeah I'll I'll be in uh
the South but we'll you know you'll
you'll see you'll see us
uh don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey
[Music]